none of its lakes kind of came in an
awkward spot as the shooter
Martin goes play the toecutter sends it
back water trying to save it
violins going to stay with Houston we're
in the screener and invite the
double-team hard gets this one off no
good rider at the back side board is not
played a whole lot in this series was
injured for the end of the regular
season
here's hard to step back off the mark
Arden hope the three from the floor has
three points Rockets lead to nothing
they've won games one and two byes
combines 52 points multiple open looks
created and not made
[Music]
transition offers two defenders
toe tap three too strong he's over six
and oh-for-three from three-point range
you have a nice new extreme
[Applause]
steal by Harden on Mitchell
gets it reticulum the first one Barney
back part with seven gets passed one guy
that's between two defenders that
opening from the floor
Rubio races ahead outs whoops Arden
toe-tap 304 11th from the floor and
Oprah six-month reach six point lead for
Utah Harden Oh 412 and fourth 473 bust
are in Houston and as a chance to his
back-to-back MVPs harden for three he
still can't make a shot he's open 1304
eight compulsive birds feet from the
floor and his team leads by two hard
drives
[Applause]
4:14 build on your lead Chris Paul with
the 5,000 snot on the floor harden for
three he's over 1500 for 9 from free
product
tried to save it Houston ball hard and
he's finally on the board with his first
field goal individual scores first field
goal in 35 9 minutes leave no doubt
James through the bucket the streak 17
straight missed field goal deep free
hard sneer and he spake two in a row in
the latest six shot clock down to five
harden against Rubio leaves and what an
answer
Cassidy James a hard-fought win despite
you going old for 15 from the field
holy yeah yes you didn't know that
oh you didn't know that all remember
Chris did you what were you saying I
went up to him right there in that time
out and I said get your swag up you know
how we play we'll play to our
percentages we'll look at how many shots
you to miss the made we put the work in
that's what you work all summer for way
we believe in and like we believe in
Giroud and everybody on our team and we
keep playing a state of course mentally
what were you going through those first
three and a half quarters before you
finally hit nothing I just aggressive
there wasn't a good job but they tested
my shot saying those shots that I should
have it's in the day I'm a little bit up
fourth quarter they fell in so you came
forward with the change then consume the
same shots